Democrats taking a big step in the push
to impeach President Trump the House
Judiciary Committee passing a resolution
outlining how impeachment hearings would
play out if Democrats decide they want
to move forward the chairman Jerry
Nadler and the ranking Republican on the
committee they're clashing over the move
with these new procedures we will begin
next week
an aggressive series of hearings
investigating allegations of corruption
obstruction and abuse of power against
the president the investigation will go
well beyond the four corners of the
Mullen report the Judiciary Committee
has became a giant Instagram filter to
make you appear that something's
happening that's not you know it's a
person who's on the spot here Dana is
Nancy Pelosi
I think she's torn between people who
say at the democratic basis says let's
have impeachment and all the members of
the Congress who actually gave them the
majority many of them coming from Trump
majority districts who don't want this I
don't think she is torn okay like so she
might have a split within our caucus I
think she knows very well that
impeachment is not a good idea and
that's why she's like okay fine go
outside and play everybody go outside
and play and then you never he's gonna
come back for dinner we're gonna vote on
the things that matter to the American
people and she'll list them out I think
that there's a parallel universe
happening with some Democrats that do
want impeachment I don't think she wants
it and I think she probably thinks well
there's only X amount of working days
between now and the end of the year
they're not gonna do impeachment before
then dress that you think Republicans
would be delighted to see Democrats in
the house try to do impeachment say oh
look at these Democrats they just got
Trump derangement syndrome no I don't
think so I don't think anybody wants
impeachment and that's actually what
Jerry Nadler said in the late 90s when
he said that you should not impeach if
it's on partisan lines you should not do
it if the country is not behind you
because it's just gonna tear the country
apart and now he's doing the exact same
thing because there's a different
president with a different letter after
his name in the White House this is like
trying to ground your child after the
kids already moved out of the house like
let it go it is over Democrats there's
nothing on collusion and the Justice
Department said no obstruction so
Nancy's right
is only gonna hurt people in swing
districts and can't believe I just say
Nancy's right I think the two things are
one whether or not there's taxpayer
dollars going to Trump properties like
he's getting that army people that's
obstruction I think what the only
taxpayer dollars here are being wasted
on another investigation and Jerry
Nadler is actually lying about this when
he says we're going to go past the four
corners of the Moller report not true
and he's also sending out fundraising
emails saying that a real impeachment
inquiry has been open so they're being
dishonest and they're wasting taxpayer
money by doing it you like this
impeachment inference oh I love it no
impeachment is what you get when you
have a great who you're living in a
great time and you're suffering from
amnesia I wasn't here yesterday for 9/11
it's nine twelve and they're not
thinking about how to prevent a 9/11
they're thinking about impeachment
that's a crime I mean at least we know
what Trump is doing about terror if it
happens again we also know what the
Democrats were doing they were doing
this and that's a shame okay